Speaker 1: Today, we're going to be speaking
with Geoff Duncan, who's the Republican lieutenant
governor of Georgia and also author of the
new book GOP 2.0 How the 2020 Election can
Lead a Better Way Forward for America's Conservative
Party. It's great to have you on. I appreciate
it.
Speaker 2: Yeah, thanks for the opportunity.
Speaker 1: So, OK, I mean, where to start,
right? Georgia has been at the center of significant
political controversy. We now know about the
various phone calls and requests to put it
lightly that were made by former President
Trump when it comes to the results of the
2020 Georgia election. I mean, is it? Give
us your sense of the direction that the Republican
Party has gone relative to where you would
like to see it as a conservative party?
Speaker 2: Yeah, there's definitely chaos
on the battlefield, for sure. And certainly
we're watching that play out in Georgia, and
I think Georgia is just a microcosm of what's
what's playing out all over the country. You
know, I'm one of those people that I'm hardwired
to be a conservative. I grew up that way.
I went to college that way. I started my first
business, raise my family. I just believe
in the conservative principles. And so it
pains me to watch the inability to win elections
because of a stylistic, because of personalities,
not because of our policies. That's painful
to watch. And then that's kind of the process
and the tug of war that we're in right now
as a Republican Party, that's really what
drove me to write GOP 2.0. It's not really
any sort of watered down, you know, policy
positions. As a conservative, it's just about
a better approach to deliver those policy
positions to America.
Speaker 1: So did did you vote for Donald
Trump in 2020?
Speaker 2: I did, I did, you know, I voted
for him in 2016, I voted for him in 2020.
I probably put myself in that category of
tens of millions of Republicans that did the
same thing that, you know, really, really
applauded the conservative wins over those
four years. But it's hard to explain to even
my own kids. I talk about this in the book
quite a bit like my three boys really shaped
a lot of kind of my positions just in raising
them with my wife. It was hard to explain,
you know, the tweets that went out, you know,
I spent all this time telling my kids, you
know, Hey, be careful what you do on social
media, you know, and then how do I explain
the former president doing what he did? Well,
how did you
Speaker 1: how did you explain? How did you
explain voting for him then?
Speaker 2: Yeah, so interesting. I talk a
lot about it and story, you know, mine was
I. I compared the Biden ideas and plans forward.
Really, what I explained it, or at least rationalized
in my mind, is really what's playing out right
now with Joe Biden. You know, I mean, nobody,
this is a nonpartisan answer to this. Nobody
agrees in my my mind that the Afghanistan
handoff was the way it was should have been
handled the way we're dealing with inflation.
The southern border, the only person I mean,
everybody believes in border security, except
for Joe Biden. So I put those elements against
what Donald Trump had done as a conservative
and and I pulled it. I pulled the the ballot
for President Trump.
Speaker 1: What exactly would Trump have done
differently on Afghanistan? Because he was
actually asked on a Newsmax interview, he
couldn't articulate a single thing he would
have done differently.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I think looking back now
in the hindsight of twenty twenty Monday morning
quarterback looks, he didn't really have an
exit strategy out of there, as thorough as
I probably thought he did. But I hope that
there was enough conservative leadership in
his administration that would have given him
better advice than what Joe Biden did and
how he executed the the exit out of Afghanistan.
That would be my hope, but it's only it's
only hypothetical.
Speaker 1: Yeah, no, because it seems since
it's the first thing you mentioned that you're
not pleased with in terms of Biden, but then
Trump can articulate what he would have done
differently. And you sort of can either other
than to say it's a hope you have. It doesn't.
It's interesting to me that that's not stylistic.
Like at first you said it, you know that they're
mostly stylistic differences with Trump. But
but policy was where you were. You would like
to see the policies enacted. But then, like
on Afghanistan, it's not really clear the
policy would have been any different. So I'm
trying to understand sort of whether your
disagreement is just on style or whether it's
policy as well.
Speaker 2: Well, we can split hairs all day
long. There's a president that's in office
and made the decisions, and his name is Joe
Biden, and there's a former president that's
not in office that did make those decisions
on exiting Afghanistan. The reality is, I
would have hoped that more military minds
would have made those realistic decisions,
and they would have had more timely, thoughtful
consideration for those that help support
our military, those that were fully expecting
to be helped through any sort of military
transition or exit out of the out of the country.
My hope is any president, whether they're
a Democrat or Republican, would have been
more thoughtful for that. But that didn't
happen. And I think that's the same thing
that we're watching play out with the southern
border. I believe in border security. It's
one of the things I talk a lot about in the
book. I think Republicans have totally dropped
the ball, including former President Trump
on immigration. We spend all this energy kind
of fearmongering about the southern border.
Yeah, and we built four hundred and sixty
miles of border wall out of a, what, two thousand
mile border or more. And the reason why I
think we've dropped the ball is we're only
having a singular focus conversation about
a big issue like immigration, border security,
but the real conversation. In addition, there's
got to be the 60 million undocumented folks
that are here, many of which we have been
full force, allowing them to be embedded in
our communities and in our economy. And we
got to have a real conversation about that.
That, to me, is an area of opportunity for
Republicans to join ranks with some of the
folks on the other side of the aisle to have
those real conversations. And I talk a lot
about that in the book.
Speaker 1: I'm curious, this is sort of kind
of like a it's a sanity check of sorts when
during the 2016 campaign where you did end
up voting for Donald Trump, when he said during
his first term he would build a wall across
all 2000 miles and Mexico would pay for it.
Did you believe that for a second? I did I'm
sorry, did you say you did not? I did not.
You did not. OK. Why do you think so many
people did believe that when he said it, when
it was so obviously going to not happen?
Speaker 2: Well, I think that's the riddle
that we're trying to solve right now is the
Republican Party is how can we get people
away? And this isn't just a Republican promise,
a Democrat from to, you know, America's addicted
to 10 second soundbites. We're making massive
political decisions and putting our support
behind folks. In short clips and certainly
GOP 2.0 is really trying to build a much more
thoughtful, thorough plan of attack on some
of these big issues ones that aren't about
280 characters on Twitter or about some slogan
called Build the Wall. What really drew the
most ire from the former president to me,
specifically during the 10 weeks of my very
intense rebuttal of the conspiracy theories
and the fraudulent, you know, the real fraud
was talking about fraud in the election cycle
here in Georgia. So my my major pushback really
started when I said, Look, Build the Wall
is a great project name, but it's not an immigration
policy. We, as Republicans, need to grasp
on to a serious immigration policy and start
to move forward. You know, that really drew
the ire of the former president, really started
a a visceral downhill spiral on whatever relationship
that was out there. Yeah.
Speaker 1: So like what happened during those
days between Election Day 2020, where we ultimately
learned the margin of victory for Joe Biden
in Georgia? Subsequently, the phone calls,
I need Brad Raffensperger to find me eleven
thousand seven hundred and eighty votes give
me a break. Like, what was what were you doing
at that time? Who were you talking to? What
were the conversations like?
Speaker 2: Yeah, so I literally within days
of the election and all of this kind of rumor
mill starting that there was fraud and whatnot,
I I don't headfirst into the details. I talked
to the governor's office. I talked to the
secretary of state and his entire team. I
talked to the attorney general. And really
the feedback I was getting is, Jeff, there's
there's no signs of any sort of systemic fraud.
There's nothing coming in other than just
wildly placed social media posts and wild
allegations starting to flow in from the Trump
administration. So I started to get as quickly
as I could get on TV for for two reasons.
One is I didn't want any sort of runaway rumor
to take over the control of the narrative
that we can run a fair, legal, you know, legal
election year in Georgia. And to what I was
trying to protect the runoff process from
two conservative U.S. senators that were now
engaged in a runoff. Unfortunately, we know
how that turned out if you're a conservative.
So I hit the TV, I probably did. I don't know
what the number is 60, 70, 80, 100 national
television interviews and radio and music
or print interviews, and I spoke up against
it. I was one of the first folks that said,
Unfortunately, I'm going to have to say Joe
Biden is the president elect. And almost instantly
drew ire from not only the former president,
but also from, you know, people all over,
all over the country. We end up, you know,
receiving threats. As a family. We have 24
hour security. I mean, it was it was an intense
10 weeks of simply, you know, just telling
the truth. And one of the surprising things
for me was, and one of the motivating factors
behind writing the book GOP 2.0 was, you know,
I thought I was walking out singing as part
of a Republican choir. But the reality was
I was singing a solo for far too long. When
the facts simply lined up that there was no
fraud, there was no systemic issues going
on. Donald Trump got beat, and he's the one
who missed the layup. And as a Republican,
I hold him accountable for not doing the things
he needed to do to win.
Speaker 1: Was there behind the scenes? Any
consideration among Brian Kemp, Brad Raffensperger
and other election officials of actually trying
to do what Donald Trump was asking to have
done?
Speaker 2: So I only speak for myself, and
the answer is no, there was no way I was going
to move my feet. This job is not worth lying
for. And I certainly wouldn't lie to 11 million
Georgians, some of them who who wanted to
see this scenario changed. But I certainly
never heard of any time. I never had a conversation
with any of the other statewide elected officials
that ever appeared to me that they were considering
it, but I'd encourage you to get their opinion
on that.
Speaker 1: Sure. So I guess as opinions aside,
as far as you know,
Speaker 2: no, just as far as I know, there
was never a consideration between the governor
or the speaker, the secretary of state and
myself to to take into consideration because
look, there was multiple avenues going at
this point. There were, you know, the former
president wanted to have a special session
to send a different set of electorates. We
wanted to have, you know, just all types of
different scenarios. We're playing out. Just
really weren't feasible.
Speaker 1: Do you think that the craziness
that took place involving these fraud claims
between November and the date of the special
elections for the Senate, which I think was
January 5th? Do you think that contributed
to both Republican senators losing their races?
Speaker 2: Yeah, one hundred percent. Absolutely.
And it was unfortunate. I don't claim to be
smarter than anybody by any stretch of the
imagination. I'm just a retired baseball player,
for the most part. But I could see it coming
from a mile away when they buy just by default
hired Donald Trump as their campaign manager
during the runoffs. That was the beginning
to the end. Georgians wanted to be reminded
of their conservative policies and positions
that they stood for. They know Georgia fell
in love with their business acumen and their
ability to articulate jobs and national security,
and all those things that really kind of are
the tenets of why, you know, we wanted them
there and why the governor and selected Kelly
Loeffler to represent Johnny Isaacson of the
remainder of his term. They forgot to do that.
And unfortunately, Donald Trump got his hooks
in them. And, you know, just made it all about
him and his conspiracy theories.
Speaker 1: Do you think that Trump's actions
in terms of the influence campaign and the
phone calls might have been criminal?
Speaker 2: So I'm not an attorney, I told
you I'm a recovering baseball player. Sure,
but based on conversations we have there.
Yeah. So look, I think I think I'll start
with they were absolutely inappropriate and
they were discussing whether I was whatever
party affiliations were associated with it.
They were just inappropriate. And I know that
there's investigations going on and they're
going to certainly get to the bottom of what
their opinions are from those legal investigations.
But I don't have the I don't have the legal
acumen not to split hairs. You know, if it
was illegal or not, it was inappropriate,
for sure.
Speaker 1: Fair. One of the the criticisms
I've had of the Republican Party of late as
someone who's not a Republican is that the
focus on policy has become close to zero and
the most prominent Republicans right now that
that get headlines federally are getting headlines
by saying that they don't want to wear masks
or they don't want people to have to get vaccinated,
or they're taking a stance against critical
race theory or forces trying to cancel Christmas.
Or now it's Halloween, I guess Fox did a bunch
of segments yesterday about Halloween maybe
getting canceled. Do you think that this is
a direction that's good for just just without
evaluating it morally, for winning races,
for winning elections? Is it good to focus
on the culture stuff instead of policy?
Speaker 2: Absolutely not. I spent a lot of
time in the book talking about it, because
look at the end of the day, we're all supposed
to be running for these offices because we
want we want to be in a position of leadership.
Right. And there's no leadership to be found
in all these short term sugar high issues.
I talk about in the book what I refer to as
my pet project policy. Empathy a tone really
is a strategy to approve all of those as a
meaningful way to win back the White House
in twenty four. And on the policy front, yeah,
we we have literally forgotten to remind America
of the policies that we, as Republicans, are
good at. Just like you mentioned, you're you're
you're part of the, you know, you're a Democrat.
Speaker 1: I'm not a Democrat. I'm I'm on
the left, but I'm not a Democrat.
Speaker 2: OK. OK, so so you're on the left.
So there's certain issues that you think the
left are better at right. That's your personal
position. Sure. Well, I think there's some
things that Americans think that Republicans
are better at. We just have totally forgotten
to remind people of those policies that we're
good at. And we've also forgotten the ability
to understand that we can lead on some of
these big issues. I talked about immigration
a second ago. Let's talk about health care.
Right. It is a it is an issue ripe for the
picking. To talk about something other than
we hate Obamacare more, you know, more to
11, right? You know, we need to put more on
the bone there. We need to talk about how
we center health care away from the government
and onto the small business owners. How do
we empower small business owners who, by the
way, are the bulk of the employers in this
country to be able to compete with big companies
and with government programs to be able to
offer affordable health insurance to their
employees and to be able to entice people
to come to work instead of just going to the
mailbox to receive those. There's so many
solutions that Republicans can come up with
health care, but we've got to be willing to
talk about it and not these sideshows and
these distraction elements and these shiny
objects that that really kind of just run
to day news cycles. And then we then we got
to hurry up, find the next one.
Speaker 1: Yeah. You mentioned 2024 and taking
back the White House, obviously, before that,
we have a midterm election in 2022. Do you
think that it helps your um, sort of. I don't
know that I call it aside, but your approach
to the Republican Party is it helped or hindered
if folks like Marjorie Taylor Greene and Lauren
Boebert and Madison Cawthorn get reelected
next year.
Speaker 2: So I don't I don't know. The only
person I really know in that mix that I know
well is Marjorie Taylor Greene, and certainly
if we have more Marjorie Taylor Greene in
Congress, we're in trouble as Republicans,
right? That's right. And I certainly have
made no no qualms about it that I think she's
destructive to our state. I think she's destructive
to our party. I think she's a person like
hers, destructive to our country. And so it's
not just enough to get Republican leadership,
but we've got to have the right Republicans.
They care about the long term viability of
conservative leadership and conservative policies
that aren't about little sideshows and press
conferences and and whatnot. You know, our
tone matters, and I talked about the pet project
policy empathy in tone. Our tone is so important.
If simply, Donald Trump had a better tone,
you know, is down the stretch you you kind
of became an adult and said, You know what?
I'm the leader of the free world, and I'm
going to use the next hundred days to really
put on display my leadership style. I'm going
to take my business resume on how I can coordinate
the vaccine distribution, how I can manage
international affairs, how I can manage an
economy that continues to whipsaw. And you
all just judge me by what I do, not by what
I said. I just that better authoritative tone
would have made mountains of difference. I
think it would have probably won him the election.
But of course, he couldn't get out of his
own way. And I talk about that in the book
with several one on one conversations with
him in the back of the piece that really kind
of led me to led me to see that smell in the
air of defeat. You could sense even as close
to the election as two days before Donald
Trump came down to Georgia for a rally in
Rome, Georgia, and I was there as one of the
speakers. And and this was this was eye opening
to me, and I spent a lot of time in the book
talking about this. I made a statement because
I was trying to win the suburbs. I knew where
we had, where we had to win was was convinced
the suburbs that he was worthy of four more
years. And I knew it was going to be close.
And I made a statement in kind of closing
of my five minute speech. I said, You know
what? Our policies are so good as Republicans.
They even help the people that don't vote
for us. And I got booed. I literally got booed
by a sea of thirty thousand Make America Great
Hats because I was willing to say that our
policies are so good they help the people
that don't vote for us, too. And that was
an eye opener to me. That one, the president
was out there campaigning one hundred miles
away from the suburbs and to there was such
a visceral reaction to even looking at trying
to help the other side or even trying to build
bridges or expand the size of the tent. Yeah,
even two days before the election, the smell
was in the air, not just in Georgia, but all
over the country.
Speaker 1: Yeah, that's a definite red flag.
No, no question. No question there. The book
is GOP 2.0. How the 2020 election can lead
to a Better Way Forward for America's Conservative
Party. We've been speaking with the book's
author, Geoff Duncan, who's the lieutenant
governor of Georgia. Really appreciate your
time and your perspective today.
Speaker 2: Yeah, thanks for the opportunity.
I really, really appreciate it.